[music playing]
We took in this
2016 Indian motorcycle
that needed some mechanical
work and a brand new paint job.
Now, the client
had a great vision
for some way cool
graphics on this thing,
with skulls, and flames, and
some beautiful Native American
imagery on the gas tank.
Shannon and Mike went above
and beyond on this motorcycle.
Come on out, Diane.
How are you?
- Good.
- Good, good, good.
Tom, are you doing, brother?
Pretty good, man.
All right.
All right, our
clients Tom and Diane,
they are here right now
to check this baby out.
So I'm going to drag Ryan
out of his turbinator cave
so he can enjoy some of
the fruits of his labor,
because, man, this boy's been
stressing out over this thing
lately.
He needs something
to smile about.
You ride a lot?
Yes.
Been riding for a long time?
- Since I was 12.
- Amen.
You are going to
go crazy on this.
Should we quit talking about it?
- I'm ready.
Should we show this thing off?
I want to get it outside,
see it in the light.
Shannon, come on, man.
Bring out that Indian.
Oh, my god.
Holy [bleep]
Oh, that looks amazing.
DANNY: We took this
2016 Indian motorcycle
and covered it in a
coat a cobalt blue
that is so bright it
looks electrified when
the sun hits it just right.
We added graphics of
flames, and skulls,
and a baby blue hand turned
leaf, and tricked out
the tank with a sick
image of a skulled
out Native American face.
We then topped off everything
with new mid-rise handlebars
for comfort, and replaced
the fender and guards.
Now this baby is as bad as
all get out and ready to ride.
Oh, I can't wait till
my buddies see this.
They're going to die.
- Oh, my gosh.
Look at it.
- You guys soak it up.
Man, take your time.
Take your time.
Holy cow.
It all flows.
The Indian on the tank
is exactly what I wanted.
Ain't no factory
paint job anymore.
No way.
That is amazing.
The team killed
it on this one.
They really did.
Those bars, your arms won't
get as sore and tired, right?
I'm glad you guys
put the bumpers on it.
You don't put that
bumper on there,
you might as well kiss
that thing goodbye.
I really do like
the cobalt blue.
It's a beautiful color.
You said you wanted
something that looks fast.
I figured the
fire's the best way
to get some action
going on without dating
the bike too much.
That thing came out beautiful.
You can't go wrong
with skulls and fire.
It's gorgeous.
Buddy, I got to tell you.
That is one hell of a job.
You hit it right
on the head, man.
I had a hell of
a team [inaudible]..
And as long as you guys
are thrilled, we're happy.
It's about to go on a
3,200-mile ride right now.
- Is it really?
- Really?
Bought it to ride.
Bro, I love it.
Yeah, man.
I would like to see
y'all try it on.
- You got it, man.
- Absolutely.
You know what I'm saying?
That's the best part.
DANNY: It is.
It is.
He fits it perfect.
- Yeah, he does.
- Oh, man.
- Absolutely.
- He fills the bike out.
I look tiny on it.
- Right?
How do those bars feel?
They feel great.
[engine revving]
Pipes sound great.
Yeah, man, test that baby out.
DIANE: Whoo.
Whoo.
Man, that Indian
looks cooler moving
than it did standing still.
I think it's very safe to say
that Tom and Diane are going
to get miles of smiles and a
whole lot of jealous bikers
as they cruise around
putting down 3,200 miles.
I think they're happy, dude.
I hope they come back, because
we still got a tab to pay.